democratic congresswoman Dina Titus
referring to our investigators report
during a trained safety Hearing in
Washington D.C she asked the president
of the American Association of railroads
about the lack of information First
Responders may get in an emergency now
the city of Las Vegas telling our
investigators the train company doesn't
tell them what's on board we also found
the County's emergency plans say to call
a phone number in case something goes
wrong
you know those train lines go right down
the strip right behind the strip right
through the the heart of town but I hear
from Las Vegas that maybe you're
notifying the state and they have a
person at the fusion Center but they
don't seem to be getting that
information how can we improve that uh
well that's something that I would love
to sit down and talk more with your
office about because we want to make
sure the right people are getting it
now there is an app that First
Responders can use to find out what is
in certain train cars Titus continue to
press that CEO about making sure those
who need the information know it before
a train even comes into the valley